so Matt for people that don't know you
came on board this movie franchise as
the director of the second film dawn of
the Planet of the Apes how did you get
involved and was this always envisioned
as a trilogy from that point where you
came on board no one told me essentially
what happened was Rupert wide who'd done
an amazing job with Rhys had worked with
them uh you know there basically is a
three-year schedule they spent the first
year trying to come to terms about what
to make and they couldn't agree and so
he left and I was called and I thought
well this is a bad way to enter a movie
I don't know he did such a beautiful job
and I was like well well so what what is
the plan because I love dries so much
and they showed me the outline and I
said oh I see well it's not it wasn't
his outline it was something that they
were trying to figure out what to do and
I said I said oh I don't think it's for
me but I do I do love this franchise and
good luck and they said no wait wait
wait wait what would you do and I said
well I don't want to tell you that
because you're going to give me some
Faustian bargain you're going to say do
37 percent of what you want and the rest
of what we want and the whole big
showdown at Candlestick Park and I was
like so but they said no just come in
and pitch us the movie and I was like
well I would want to see a movie that
you know really followed I thought the
big secret of Rhys was that the point of
view at the end of the movie was
actually in Apes the most human
character in that film was an ape and I
thought that was so powerful and I was
like I think you want to take this you
know the story that they had didn't have
Caesar as central and I was like I think
it should start in the woods I want it
when he says Caesar is home I want to
see the home that he and the Apes and
make it like dawn of you know
intelligent apes like dawn of man in
2001 or something and I pitched out what
I thought it would be and they literally
said to me that sounds great are you in
and I was like whoa you saying I can
make that movie and they said yeah I
said okay what's the caveat and they
said the caveat is these movies take
like three years but you're going to
have to and I didn't know what that
meant because I was stupid I had no idea
I hadn't done you know any any and so
that's how I got into that and then on
this one they liked the movie so much on
this one at the end they said hey listen
why don't you do another one and I said
great I would love to and you know we
knew we wanted it to be this kind of
last leg of the Caesar journey
but there was no story that we hadn't
talked about it being trilogy and they
said listen you did that one in two
years how about this one
and I was like No so this one took three
years Joey you've been involved in all
three of the films how has the
technology changed in the amount of
years from the first one to the third
one
have there been leaps and bounds well
the technology change really happened
the big change was for the first film we
we'd been lucky to work with Andy Serkis
a lot in the past we done Gollum and
King Kong together he played you know
Captain Haddock when we did Tintin so
we've been using this idea of
performance captured to render Andy's
performance to the screen for quite a
long time but it was always a process
where Andy would be there for the actors
like well you know like say when he was
doing Gollum Peter would be shooting and
he was in there the actors were working
with them they benefited from that give
and take but Andy then had to go back
and redo this performance for us in what
was basically a gym with a bunch of
cameras around it was very much like a
science experiment and you know we
thought when it came time to do then
once we knew Andy was was in a Caesar he
was going to do the part I thought we
really owe it to him to get that
performance he's giving on the day you
know I don't want to say to Andy after
all this time can you do it again so we
really set to mind how can we capture it
live and there's you know you're dealing
with with cameras and lights and they
tend to interfere with the film cameras
and light so that's that's been the
basic problem but we figured out a way
to crack that and we would hang our
cameras around the set and it became
part of the live action shooting so in
the first film which was mostly you know
on stages but also some exterior
locations we had Andy working with the
actors and the performance that he gave
was the performance that made it to the
film so for us that that was the big
breakthrough after that Matt decided to
make it hard decided he decided that
okay that's great that that works but it
really allows us to take the story
elsewhere you know to take it to the ape
village and then to take it on this
great Exodus and you know to me I think
about it in the way that like it must
have been in the days when you you we're
doing sound you had a big blimp on the
camera
couldn't move it anywhere then someday
you figured out how to make it lighter
and move it a little bit farther and
that's kind of where I think we're going
with it you know like if Matt says I
wanted you to do the next one
wherever it might be we want to be ready
for that because that's really what this
is all about it's just it's being there
to help tell the story
huge Steve Zahn fan I've loved him from
that thing you do in suburbia
- happy Texas that all the other great
stuff he's done how did you know in
meeting with him that he could do this
very particular kind of acting job that
you need to be able to do for this okay
so that's the perfect question he wasn't
doing a certain kind of acting job in
the sense that I think people think you
have to understand that this the
performance capture is exactly that it's
a system of cameras that records a
performance you've got tracking markers
you've got cameras and what are the
actors doing they're performing and
that's it there's no like learning like
everyone talks about like you know Andy
Serkis he's the greatest mocap actor in
history which is literally a meaningless
designation because what he is is one of
the greatest actors on the planet and
he's so incredible and and you have to
understand that the artistry that it
takes in this movie to get that
performance comes from a couple places
one is first with his performance he's
incredible and then the other thing that
happens is these incredible artists at
whether they are translating that
performance and the reason has to be
translated is because you have Andy's
face and when you look at Andy's face he
makes you feel a certain way and then
you want Caesar to make you feel the
same way but it's a different Anatomy so
that requires that's not like hey you
know some people think oh well Andy just
is the voice no Andy is the performance
and some people think oh well whether
they have all these technical things and
they push a button know what they are is
all these incredible animators who have
to find out the way what we do is we
take the shots of the actors and we put
them up side by side with every
submission of the performance that's
that's been animated and we look at it
and go oh you know Andy looks he looks
really angry but he's also sad and it's
that mix of emotions that makes you feel
that and Caeser right now I can see the
anger but the sadness is not there yet
and then we get into this discussion
with the enemies oh yeah well that's
because Andy on his brow he's got this
shape but Caesar doesn't have that and I
go we need that don't we nee go well we
have to figure out how to get that shape
to be there because we experience
emotion based on the expressions we see
on actors faces so this is the crazy
alchemy that comes together is
translating shot by shot all of those
things so that was a long answer as a
lead-in into why so the reason I cast
Eve's on is because when he read for me
over Skype because he was in Puerto Rico
doing a TV series and we were talking
about the thing we did the scene where
he and Caesar are talking about their
children and he made me cry and I was
like this guy is amazing and he told me
that this performance which by the way
he said has now been like his favorite
experience out of anything that he's
done because he said it was the most
pure experience of acting mocap acting I
mean everything that we do on the set is
about creating an atmosphere it's no
different from doing an independent
movie where you get the actors together
and you can search you go on an
emotional search for the truth of the
scene it's everything after that that's
insane
then we have to get those shots again
then we have to do all these other
passes and then of course we have to
spend over a year afterwards working
with Wetty to make sure those
performances are on these Apes but the
actors the first thing they do all this
thing about moving like an ape you know
an actor if he plays someone who is in
an accident and they have a limp they
have to learn that as the baseline
that's just his walk
that's not his heart so so Steve and
Andy they learn how to move and to
express themselves in a way that
reflects their character they have to
play chimps and carry notary who's a
genius it has worked with all the actors
to get them to perform in this way but
that is not the half of it that's just
the beginning then they give these
performances and the reason I cast Yves
on is he's a great actor so Joe Matt was
talking about the shortened time frame
for Dawn but also this one didn't have a
ton of time either where there are times
where you felt I just need a couple more
weeks here my team and I need some more
time or did you feel like you've gotten
to the point where you were able to do
it under a tight deadline every film was
like that you you worked at available
time it's really you know just
discussions with with Matt and looking
at the film and looking at
every shot and saying this is what we
need this is what we have to go for and
if we had six more weeks it wouldn't
have been like they were six easy weeks
we would just keep doing the same thing
so that's that's what it's all about
you're just trying to make the most out
of the film in the time that you've got
am i correct at every spear in those
battle scenes every spear is not not
everyone but most okay yeah there's some
there there are the practical Spears
that are there so like when you have
spear riding the horse that's what we
called him his character's name is spear
but he's the guy who is riding that
horse and kind of cursed that with like
moment when he's like rearing up and
he's got that that's actually a stunt
guy riding with the spear and Weda
decided hey let's keep that spear cuz
that's a real thing you have try to have
as much so the horse is real and they
actually paint out the rider and then
put the a pin and so there's a bit of
something real and then there's
something totally created and it's this
whole magic of what they do
congratulations Matt Reeves and Jolla
Terry